we had a bit of an update about the
Orville and it's not necessarily good
news
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so I'm going to start off by saying the
update here is that there really isn't
an update it actually is just kind of
confirming what I've already told you
guys the Disney and Hulu would be very
interested in doing the Orville but a
top guy from Hulu Disney scripting
material for streaming has been talking
about it and if you read between the
lines well a couple of people including
screenland have already reported that it
looks like the end of the road for the
Orville but I'm here to tell you
actually I don't think we need to be too
worried just yet and I've got a couple
of really good reasons why so the person
in question is actually the Hulu
original on ABC entertainment president
and he is actually also the president of
scripted material for streaming for
Disney uh his name is Craig irwik and
what did he have to say we don't have
anything to share right now it's a great
show and I know that the fans loved
having him back in their lives and Seth
MacFarlane did a great job uniquely as
he can in front of and behind the camera
but we don't have anything to share
right now
right well you will know that I actually
updated you first and exclusively a
couple of months ago about the Orville
and I told you that Disney Hulu are very
very interested in creating another
series of the Orville following the
success of New Horizons but that they
were not gonna do it for the money that
they spent on New Horizons now the show
did really really well but it didn't do
well enough to Warrant the budget which
was four New Horizons massive so they
are negotiated with separland to bring
the show in it is a slightly lower cost
now I don't have any issue with that I
actually think this is a very character
driven TV show anyway I think some of
the on-screen special effects
particularly in the first series were
not really necessary I'm thinking about
the first episode with a little fighter
thing going in and out the ships and
being chased if that's the whole scene
hadn't been in the series I wouldn't
have bothered I wouldn't have interested
I it wouldn't have bothered me in the
slightest so I do think it's possible
that they he could cut back on some of
those effects without actually losing
anything in the show because you know
it's it's a counter-driven show anyway
and that's really what we want to see
even though the Space Battles are
awesome we don't need maybe quite so
many
but there are other issues now it's not
just the money issue that my sources
told me about he has also said and
pointed out that Seth MacFarlane is
incredibly busy so nothing really is
going to be greenlit and nothing is
going to be announced until they get to
the point where Seth MacFarlane can
actually make the time to do it he is
currently doing a prequel for his Ted
series of movies he's obviously very
busy on other projects so we really have
to wait for there to be a time and a
place that everybody can get together to
do the series they're not going to
announce it until Seth MacFarlane can
say when he's going to sit down and
write the series
but I am really really confident that it
will happen for another reason as well
streaming services unlike networks don't
need to do a series every year now I
know it's been five months or so since
um the last series ended so you would
expect a new series to start in the next
few months but that was our networks
when they had to have a series every
year nowadays they just don't look at
stranger things they're talking about
that maybe being late 2024 good 18
months two years between series look at
Lord of the Rings rings of power that
might not be even until 2025 potentially
so nowadays with streaming services
there isn't the demand for a series
every single year like they used to be
so again Hulu and Disney are not really
in any rush they can wait for Seth
MacFarlane but do we think Seth
MacFarlane wants to do another series of
the Orville
hell yeah look at his Twitter feed it's
all he ever bloody talks about so yes he
100 would love to do another series and
now he's been given the Freedom by
Disney to do the series he actually
wants to do and he actually wants to do
a love letter to Star Trek a proper
Sci-Fi show instead of the screwball
comedy adult penis fart jokes that he
was forced to put into the first series
by the executives now he's actually able
to do that grown-up Sci-Fi show that he
always wanted I think he will come back
to the Orville as soon as he's able so
the update from my sources is simply
wait and see Don't Panic it is going to
come but it might take a little bit
longer than we wanted and that is just
the reality of streaming services
nowadays
so be patient
but guys I'd love you to get into the
comments what do you think about this
update of not an update or uh are you
excited about the possibility of the
Orville returning and would you rather
it just happens when it happens or do
you want it right now or not at all get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
and if you want to support the channel
even further and become a fully fledged
site tracker hit the join button
we'll also go to the description we've
got links for our Chevron 9 our Stargate
website uh merchandise website uh
Facebook group all of that sort of thing
the links are in the description
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]